so looking at decoupling our production  and consumption cycles from natural  resource use and environmental intensity  and when you think about it to do that  you need all of the power that comes  from digital technology social mobile  cloud analytics Internet of Things all  these things are enabling us to both by  use and reuse resources in a radically  new way so for example in the Internet  of Things when you look at organizations  like Vodafone who are providing the  wireless technologies and communications  through machine-to-machine communication  to radically reshape the way we use  energy in buildings driving smart  metering smart grids really being able  to make us communicate in an energy  system in a way that we never have been  able to before  that's the convergence of digital and  sustainability and for me that's the  most exciting thing at this point in  time in the energy industry